MANO MARKS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Mano Marks.
This is Susannah Raub
and Marcelo Camelo.
We're on the Google
Maps API team.
Marcelo and Susannah have kindly
agreed to join us from
the Sydney office.
They're here for Google I/O and
they'll be talking to you
in just a moment about their
sessions at Google I/O.
Susannah is the Tech Lead for
the Google Maps API, and
Marcelo is the Tech Lead for
the Google Places API.
So we're really excited
to have them here.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Google Maps API developer
relations team.
Hi, welcome guys.
SUSANNAH RAUB: Thanks, Mano.
MARCELO CAMELO: Thank
you, Mano.
MANO MARKS: Thanks
for joining us.
So the first thing I want to do
is ask each of you to give
us a little summary of what
you're going to be talking
about in your sessions.
So let's start with
you, Susannah.
SUSANNAH RAUB: Sure.
My talk next week is called,
Maps API Best Practices, and
along with my teammate, Jez, we
will be talking about, sort
of, common traps people fall
into in using the Maps API, as
well as some things you can do
to make your map a little bit
better and then some things to
make your map really awesome.
So going through some old
features and new features that
will really make a
good map great.
MANO MARKS: Can you give any
hints on things that you're
going to be talking about
specifically?
SUSANNAH RAUB: I think-- so
we'll be showing some demos
that use a combination of our
many services and features.
And I think some of those show
some compelling uses of the
Maps API that perhaps some
developers haven't thought of
to use before.
MANO MARKS: OK, great.
And Marcelo, do you want to--
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah.
So the name of our talk is,
Building a Business Around the
Places API.
So we'll be giving an overview
of what Places API is.
We also want to go into some
basic principles that we think
developers should keep in mind
when building applications
using the Places API and also
when they're aiming to
actually turn that
into a business.
MANO MARKS: Great, great,
it sounds great.
I'm also going to be giving a
talk on enterprise uses of
Google Maps API, but you're here
to talk to Susannah and
Marcelo today.
So just a reminder, all
the content that is--
all the sessions that are at
Google I/O will be recorded,
and so you'll get a chance, even
if you don't get to go to
Google I/O, you'll
get a chance to
see all that content.
I wanted to ask each of you--
I ask everybody this, so please
forgive me-- but what
are your favorite
maps API sites?
Susannah, let's start
with you.
And I'd asked them previously,
so we have this loaded up.
SUSANNAH RAUB: My favorite
changes from time to time, but
right now, I thought
this one was pretty
cool that I just saw.
So this is in time for the
London Olympics, it's a site
that the BBC has done called
London Calling.
Some things that I--
MANO MARKS: Let me get
this on Screen Share
here for the Hangout.
Sorry, I just realized that
I need to do that.
Here we go.
SUSANNAH RAUB: So some of things
I like about this site.
First, fairly simple.
I like that they
have customized
their use of the controls.
So instead of having all of our
default controls showing
all the time, they just have the
zoom control and they've
set the min and max zoom so
that you just are seeing
London, and it does not
encourage you to go look at
the rest of the world.
They also are using styled
maps, so that you get the
features of London without
having the map actually be the
main focus here.
The map is sort of the backdrop
for the content that
they've put on top of it.
So then when you click on these
circles, these areas of
London, you get some features
within them.
Then if you can close this.
It's sort of up at
the top there.
OK.
And if you click on a marker,
here's where it
gets kind of cool.
They have this info window that
comes up on top with a
cutout showing the marker
in the middle.
And you can use the arrows
to click back and forth.
MANO MARKS: Oh, that's
very cool.
SUSANNAH RAUB: It's
pretty cool.
I think this really shows well
creative ways to display data
on top of the map.
And I love the use of the styled
maps to convey this.
MANO MARKS: Marcelo,
you had a couple?
MARCELO CAMELO: Oh, yeah.
So one of them is Skyvi, I think
that's how you pronounce
it, which is an app that
does voice commands.
And you can do, "pizza near me,"
or "closest Starbucks,"
and it works really well.
Really well.
And it uses the Places API for
all its local results.
MANO MARKS: That's on
Android, right?
MARCELO CAMELO: That's
on Android.
And then another one
is, WhatsApp.
Which is a really popular
messaging app and it's closed
platform, and allows you to,
when you're sending a message,
you can tag the message with
the location and uses the
Places API to allow you
to do a snap-to place.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
All right, let's turn
off screen share.
Those are some great
applications.
So anything you're excited
about, about Google I/O?
Anything you're particularly
looking forward to?
SUSANNAH RAUB: Oh, I always
enjoy just going to Google
I/O. I think my favorite thing
is actually getting a chance
to meet developers
face-to-face.
Marcelo and I don't get
to do that very often.
We just read comments
on the web.
So I think that's my favorite
part, usually the fireside
chat, hearing people's
questions, and compliments,
and rants, all of them.
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah
it's definitely the
highlight of my year.
I've been actually present to
all Google I/Os so far, never
missed one.
I don't want to miss this one.
I actually went through
the schedule and
I've signed up for--
I've chosen 16 sessions
to attend.
So it's going to be pretty
intense, and really looking
forward to it.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
All right.
Well, I think it might be time
to take some questions.
So why don't we see
if there's any
questions from the Hangout.
Anybody in the Hangout
have some questions?
If you have a question--
well, I can't actually see
anybody on the Hangout.
Can you raise your hand if you
want to ask a question.
I am not seeing anyone.
OK, so it looks like
we don't have any
questions from the Hangout.
So maybe if we can mute all
those folks, and then I'll
just take a look at the
moderator where we have a few
questions here that people
submitted beforehand.
So the first question, "How can
I write tests against my
web application that uses
the Google Maps API?
Do you have any mocks available
you could share
similar to your externs?"
SUSANNAH RAUB: So we don't
currently have any mocks.
You can certainly use mocking
frameworks to--
and use the externs.
First of all, I will definitely
encourage you write
tests, and I'm glad somebody
has asked this question.
I think this is something we
want to encourage, and so it's
really nice to see developers
coming to us and asking first
before we even have to tell
you should be doing this.
So you can use some--
you can mock classes using
the externs that
are available today.
We don't have any separate
mocks available, but most
testing frameworks should have
a mocking system, and the
externs will work to do that.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
So the next question is, "Will
Google be releasing a native
iOS app now that MapKit in iOS
6 is changing to use Apple's
maps?"
We don't tend to talk about
things we're going to be doing
before we do them, so we can't
really comment on what our
future plans are.
We're, of course, always
interested in mobile
platforms, particularly
Android and iOS.
So we can't tell you what
our future plans
are, at this point.
But thanks for asking that.
So the next question is, "Any
idea when we'll start to see a
Google Maps API that lets us
build real HTML5 experiences?"
I think this is getting at
basically, when will we see
the Maps GL experiment that's
currently running on
maps.google.com available
in the API?
SUSANNAH RAUB: We can't comment
on exact plans here.
It is something that we're
interested in.
We still see issues around
browsers being able to support
WebGL to the extent that we need
them to in order to run
the API across the
web using WebGL.
Certainly something to watch
for in the future.
No concrete plans for
you to announce.
MANO MARKS: And for those of you
who don't know more about
this experiment, basically,
maps.google.com is running an
experiment that uses vector
rendering in WebGL, instead of
map tiles, for all
the Maps data.
And it's a really exciting and
slick experience if you have
Chrome, or Safari, or Firefox,
one of the browsers that
supports WebGL, and a pretty
nice graphics card.
You may notice your fan spinning
up really fast.
We've also been doing a number
of different tests and demo
apps using WebGL to display
on top of Google Maps.
For instance, some stuff
that Chris and I--
Chris Broadfoot and I-- talked
about it at Strata.
And also Brendan Kenny and I are
going to be doing a code
lab at Google I/O, talking about
using different aspects
of HTML5 with your mapping
experience.
So have a lookout for
those resources.
OK so then the next question
is, "Is there a way to use
WeatherLayer as a Google Maps
service to find nearest
marker's forecast?
Something like Get Panorama
By Location in Streetview
Service."
SUSANNAH RAUB: No, the
WeatherLayer is purely a layer
on top of the map.
I think what you're asking
for is a weather service.
Go ahead and file a feature
request for that.
No promises, but we'd
love to see feature
requests for such things.
MANO MARKS: And by the way,
we have an issue tracker.
Just search for GMaps API
Issues, and that's where you
can file feature requests
and bugs, as well.
And next question, "Can a marker
be more than just an
image without having to write
your own custom overlay?"
SUSANNAH RAUB: No a marker
is just an image.
There are some libraries
that do this for you.
So our developer relations team,
Luke and Chris, wrote a
few different marker
applications.
One is an HTML marker, so this
does all the wrapping of the
custom overlay for you.
And I believe it is
still dragable.
So you can use that library.
There' s also one-- they have
a label marker-- which puts
text with markers.
But otherwise, if you want to
have custom DOM elements and a
custom look, you do need to
write a custom overlay.
MANO MARKS: And those libraries
are in the Google
Maps API utility library,
which is linked off our
documentation, or you can
just search for it.
Make sure you're looking
at the v3, not
the v2, utility library.
Question about how to get in
touch with a Google Maps for
Business sales rep.
If you're having trouble,
just ping me.
Just share a post with your
contact info with me on
Google+, and I'll forward that
onto the sales folks.
"What are some best practices
for implementing an existing
v3 map into a Drupal 7
environment?" I have no idea.
I'm not a Drupal
person at all.
So no clue.
Any?
No Drupal folks on the--
sorry about that.
I'm sure there are Drupal
communities who would be happy
to help out with this.
And the last question, I
can't really make out.
It says, "What is the best way
to get volume on a website?"
And the user name is Evil_troll,
so I'm just going
to leave it at that.
Wow.
OK.
It looks like the Hangout
has some weird screen
sharing going on.
OK.
So any questions from
the Hangout?
Anybody have a question, just
raise your hand, and we'll see
if we can answer it.
OK.
No questions.
So I think we'll go ahead
and wrap it up then.
Thank you guys for coming in,
and thanks for joining us for
the office hours everyone.